and now please direct your attention to
the video board for a special
presentation with the 20th pick
karis levert from the university of
michigan
i always had confidence in myself that i
could play and obviously a team had
confidence as well so i'm blessed
that means everything to have a group of
people like that really look at you
and really see the future
i'll always remember those
please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a salute to karis levert
and the imaginary crowd is loving it
225 career games with the nets
and what we saw sarah was development
maturity and a player who really came
into his own
in a nets uniform his work ethic was
second to none
and we can gush about the player that he
has developed into and so much brighter
of a future even not even scratching the
surface of his potential but the human
being he is the person he is
the character and integrity that he
brought to the locker room
to this organization each and every day
is something
that i know we all appreciated so very
much